since the rise of hedge funds to the day
hedge funds are like the apex predators
of wall street
instead of making money by predicting
outcomes they engineer the outcomes
these are the apex predators of wall
street
they are in the business of shorting
companies
to destroy them i mean that is their
business model and they are not
academic traders okay who are just
speculating on outcome
they engineer the outcome right look at
their tactics just watch the show
billions right they hire pr
people they hire private investigators
they're participating on these message
boards
spreading disinformation they try to
destroy companies to engineer that
outcome they create nothing
they're in the business of destruction
so we have
short seller billionaires in america
that all they do is shorting companies
yeah a big group can come in and crush a
company
simply because well we're gonna make a
lot of money i haven't made my
haven't made my quota this month or what
have you so i
i really don't care for it these guys
are regularly known for collaborating
with each other in very legal ways like
online forums
but in person yeah and by the way those
forums exist
uh in the professional organized world
too amongst hedge funds you know
i've been invited to idea dinners where
we all get together and we talk about
the ideas that we have
and in very less legal ways and being
that they have 3.4 trillion dollars
under management altogether
when they move together they can move
entire markets crush companies skyrocket
companies
hedge funds are the scavengers of the
financial sector and that a select few
have
undue influence on the markets any
public statement you make or position
you take
can send a stock soaring or falling they
make billions in profits and when a
giant crisis comes
they socialize the losses onto the
public while arguably not adding much
value to society pretty clever business
model if you ask me
what exactly is the societal value of
these hedge funds now i know that they
provide
some price discovery and they provide
greater liquidity to markets but is that
really worth
them really being the richest players in
the game
it doesn't make any sense and then when
they lose like in 2008
they get bailed out and since the
inception of the stock market
big players like hedge funds and
institutional investors have always had
an advantage over the little guy in
money
power and influence and by the way guys
before we continue i'm on stereo now
i partnered with them for this video and
i just had my first live talk on stereo
with my close business friend wally went
on how to evade texas
legally wally just moved to puerto rico
to take advantage of their amazing flat
4 percent tax rate a few weeks ago
and i have been dying to figure out how
he's been liking it so i thought i might
as well make our more casual
conversation live so you guys can learn
from it too
and what's cool about stereo is that you
guys can ask me questions and interact
with me live on the show
i'm kind of curious as to like the
living status
in puerto rico like is it comfortable i
don't know is that a third world country
that's funny yeah we talked about that
earlier a little bit actually we had a
super great time it's right up your
guys's alley evading taxes legally
so if you missed it you can check out
the replay of our chat with the link
below
and i'll be hosting a few more lives one
on friday at 12 p.m u.s pacific time
with my youtuber friend captain sinbad
you might have seen his hilarious
watches once videos what gives you so
much energy
gratitude super funny guy in real life
and another one on monday at 12 p.m with
arvid ali where he's going to be
responding to all the hate comments he's
received on our last video on kathy wood
this one is going to be pretty spicy
you're not going to want to miss it so
come hang out come chat with us at
stereo.com jake tran and be sure to hit
the notification bell on there too
so you get notified when we go live
that's again friday at 12 p.m with
captain sinbad and money at 12 p.m with
orphan ali at stereo dot com
jake tran link below january 2012
a guy named jamie rogozinski got bored
of the idea of safe investing
he found existing online forums to be
too risk averse
and couldn't stand hearing another word
about the fundamentals of a company from
talking heads on tv
so he launched a new subreddit one
called wall street bets
with the slogan being it's like 4chan
found a bloomberg terminal
one might imagine that jaime is probably
some basement dweller with greasy
fingers and potato chips on his shirt
but he's actually a respectable looking
entrepreneur with his own family
april 2013 within 15 months of the
founding of wall street bets
a new startup was founded in silicon
valley a baby named robin hood
at first it was just an app that allowed
you to track stocks no buying or selling
one and a half years later on december
2014 robin hood launched a zero
commission trading platform on the app
store
forever changing the landscape of stock
brokerages by doing the same thing that
companies like facebook did
they took something that was
inaccessible stock trading where you had
to pay a few dollars per trade on
outdated intimidating looking apps
and made it accessible by finding a new
way to make money elsewhere
in this case by selling your trading
data to bigger players
october 24th 2015 as robin hood opened
the door for more and more average
everyday people to get into the stock
market
a community like wall street bets was in
the perfect position to grow
and by now they were already developing
their own subculture a subculture of
artists or degenerates yellowing their
life savings on risky stock place
they call themselves autists or
degenerates which are basically people
that are horrible at making stock trades
without even attracting the membership
of martin shreli everyone's favorite big
pharma ceo
who was very well loved in the community
fast forward a little over a year later
in january 2017
and wall street bets crosses the
milestone of a hundred thousand
degenerates
at the same time robinhood was also
growing with over 200 000 daily active
users
april 2017 robin hood raises 110 million
dollars at evaluation of 1.3 billion
dollars
bringing the company into unicorn
territory december 2017
robin hood introduces options trading
one of the riskiest forms of trading
where you can make even more profit and
losses with less money
opening the app up to an even wider more
risky audience
a feature that will play a key role
later in the story options also allow
you to short a stock
may 2018 the growth continues robin hood
has nearly 700
000 daily active users and they raised
another 363 million at a valuation of
5.6 billion
october 2018 wall street bets rise the
wave of millennial trading with over 300
000 degenerates
nearly the same number of bloomberg
terminals the software that
professionals use for research and
trading that cost
twenty four thousand dollars per year
fun fact at 325 000 terminal
subscriptions
bloomberg is bringing in 7.8 billion per
year
june 2019 the black swan takes shape
gamestop releases a poor earnings report
cancels dividend payments to people who
own the stock
analysts downgrade the stock and the
overall consensus was that gamestop much
like the blockbusters and toys r us
before them
was as good as dead so their stock
tumbled
which on the surface is like duh of
course they're doomed that was my first
reaction
which sounds oddly familiar to the
consensus that back in the early 2000s
that duh
the housing market is never gonna crash
at the same time a user on wall street
best name deep
in value or dfv for short yolo's 50
thousand dollars in call options for the
stock
betting that is going to go up based on
some legitimate reasons in june of 2019
a wall street bets user named deep
[ __ ] value began buying long dated
january 21 calls what that means is
in june of 19 this person was betting
that the stock would go up by january of
2021.
dfv also comes off as a pretty
respectable guy
i'm thinking seeing a legitimate
investment process like mine in action
day to day
could help set you on the right path to
building out your own investment process
over time
the gamestop thesis is super simple but
it's often misunderstood
everyone classifies it as a cigar and
then just moves on but it's more than
that july 2019
one month later robin hood raises
another 329 million
raising its valuation to a staggering
7.6 billion
august 2019 one month after that michael
bury the investor that shorted the
housing bubble and was portrayed by
christian bale in the big short
announces that he owns three percent of
gamestop and he also gives some
legitimate reasons why he thinks the
company is worth more than it is
with the main reason that being 90 of
gamestop's 5 700 stores are free cash
flow positive
they're not losing money or in other
words michael brewery and the reddit
user
started this whole trend based on some
real fundamental reasons fundamental
analysis as they call it
wall street best soon takes notice of
burry's position and dfv starts posting
monthly updates on his gamestop yellow
at this time he's already up 50 thousand
dollars on his original 50k
december 2019 robin hood launches a new
feature that lets you buy fractional
shares
keeping their promise of further
democratizing investing by making it
even easier for more people to get into
stock trading
march 2020 the pandemic has shut down
the economy and would you look at that
i just got a 1200 welfare i mean
stimulus check
and maybe i got even more free money in
the form of unemployment aid
well i'm stuck at home where should i
put my money
why not the stock market
[Music]
so interest in stock trading surges and
practically at the exact same moment
the stock market starts its greatest
climb ever which is a big reason why we
haven't seen a lot of inflation yet
watch this video to learn more wall
street bets crosses 1 million
degenerates
and robin hood crosses 2 million users
april 3rd 2020
gamestop hits a low of 2.57
august 31st 2020 the billionaire founder
of the successful pet
e-commerce company called chewie.com
buys a nine percent stake in gamestop
making him yet another big name to show
support for the brick and mortar chain
everyone thinks is gonna die
september 19 2020
[Applause]
a member of wall street bets writes
basically a stock analysis like the pros
do on why gamestop could be a winner
the next generation of consoles will
still be using this they're not going
all digital just yet
like michael burry said the company's
fundamentals are not bad but most
importantly
gamestop was the most shortest stock on
the stock market at the time
with around 120 of their stock shorted
see when you buy a stock the most money
you can lose is the money you put in
but the most you can gain is however
high the stock goes there's no limit to
how much you can make
but when you shorter stock this gets
reversed the most you can gain is a
stock going to zero but the most you can
lose is however high the stock goes
there's no limit to how much you can
lose think about margin call is there's
limited loss right there's only so much
you can lose
now when it comes down to shorting
shorting
shorting can get people to take their
lives which is something
graham stefan has a great video
explaining short selling and if you
check it out just let him know that i
sent you
since so many people were shorting
gamestop this reddit user theorized that
once the market realizes that gamestop
is not all that bad and more good news
comes out
the price will rise forcing the short
sellers to exit their positions
which will drive the price higher which
will force more shorts to exit which
will create a positive feedback loop of
the stock skyrocketing
an extreme short squeeze and if everyone
bought at around the same time
they could accelerate the short squeeze
even more skyrocketing their profits in
the process
the only thing left that they needed was
for some good news to come out
january 12 2021
[Music]
ryan cohen and gamestop reach an
agreement earning him and his ceo and
cfo a seat on the board of directors
because they have so much experience in
e-commerce ryan cohen is viewed as a
saver of gamestop
the stock closes at around 20 on january
12 2021.
chatter about gamestop explodes in
online forums like wall street bets
and the degeneres got to thinking that
maybe this short squeeze idea wasn't so
crazy after all
the battle lines are drawn and the game
is set gamestop closed at 1995 on
january 12th
on one side you had institutional
investors and hedge funds that thought
gamestop was for sure going
to perish shorting the stock pushing it
downward and on the other side you had
the degenerates on wall street bets
buying the stock and buying call options
for the stock pushing it upward
the institutional guys are like hey wait
a minute you know
ryan cohen's an idiot this company is
[ __ ]
[ __ ] these guys they have too many you
know cyclical and secular tailwinds
and they become so massively short that
the infrastructure that's supposed to
even count all the shares
can't keep up and now they are short
more than the actual number of shares
that actually exist so now they're 140
short january 13th gamestop is up to
31.40
or up 57 january 14th
39.91 up 100 from the start
january 19th degenerates hold the line
at 39.36
short sellers start to sweat but
doubling down in their position
now it becomes a game of protecting
their ego citron research a big short
seller calls the degenerate suckers at
this poker game
later calling them an angry mob and what
started out as a genuine strategy for
the retail investors to make money
has turned into an all-out proxy war
representing the little guy versus the
establishment of wall street
as news starts to spread on social media
more and more average people get in on
the action
then over the next two days gamestop
calls
hit an all-time high and it runs a
two-day rally of almost 70 percent and
this is what really starts what's called
the gamma squeeze
friday january 22nd gamestop becomes so
volatile that trading is halted at least
four times
the stock closes at 65.01 up to 126
percent since the start of the battle
the stock market closes for the weekend
and the number of degenerate on wall
street bets starts to explode
at some point in this process the
degenerates recruited some unlikely
allies
quant funds and other hedge funds that
saw an opportunity to get on the right
side of the battle
then a bunch of quant funds and momentum
hedge funds notice all this activity
and they also participate on the long
side
and then over the past seven trading
days we have traded over 100 billion
dollars of stock in gamestock which is
well
in excess of what retail can support so
quant funds are funds that use
mathematical models and computer
algorithms to trade
after all why wouldn't you use an
opportunity like this to wipe out some
pesky competitors
then comes monday january 25th one of
the major hedge funds that was short in
gamestop
melvin capital is on the brink of
collapse so they got a near 3 billion
bailout by two other hedge funds
gamestop closes at 76.79
up 285 percent since the start tuesday
january 26th
elon musk tweets gamestock and support
linking to wall street bets
continuing the subreddit's explosion and
growth now elon may genuinely support
the fight for the little guy
but remember elon hasn't asked the
ground with short sellers
which elon refers to as a scam releasing
tesla short shorts after defeating them
the way short selling is used today is
it's it's kind of like a
it's frankly used against the public
tesla is under a massive attack by the
shortened distort
where they take a short position and
then they do everything possible to
trash the company in every
six weeks of sunday and they were
successful um and
and this has now happened to tesla twice
it happened in 2013
and it happened in in basically 2017
through through 2019
i mean the intensity of the attack was
was was crazy it would like cause you to
lose faith in humanity the
degree of this which this went on what
you may not know is that melbourne
capital the fund that was just bailed
out has been shorting tesla for years
that infinite short squeeze loop kicks
into high gear and gamestop explodes to
147.98 that day
up an insane 642 percents
wednesday january 27 to thursday january
28th
everything has been leading up to this
point and the little guy puts what seems
to be the final nail in the coffin for
the shorts
gamestop closes at 347.51 up 135
from just yesterday and up 1642
from the start our guy deep in value's
original 50 000
is now at 48 million dollars but then
everything falls apart discord bans the
wall street bet server citing hate
speech
because of course they would and this is
exactly what i've been talking about
with censorship it starts with something
you like and then becomes something you
don't how many of the people
who support these you know reddit kids
were in favor of de-platforming trump
and parlor and now they can see where it
goes this is a slippery slope and we've
only had to wait three weeks to see
where it goes
it goes to the same place which is when
the people in power get
threatened they use these rules they
weaponize these rules
to shut down the outsiders and the
upstarts that is a problem with
censorship
that is why you cannot let the beast get
started
and the next day just ask the shorts
were right where they should be
robin hood and other broker brokerages
restrict the buying of meme stocks like
gamestop
one could still sell their shares
helping wall street but one couldn't buy
gamestop falls to 193.60 at the close
down 44 from the day before the
beautiful thing is you had these reddit
kids these pirates
who published this manifesto right on
reddit
basically being the heirs to occupy wall
street they recognize look
occupying physical space does nothing to
these guys
we are going to hurt them where accounts
in their pocketbook we are going to get
together
and we're going to basically create a
trade mob that's even bigger than their
cartel
and they did they got 2.7 million people
taking the other side of this trade and
then when the hedge funds doubled down
they said [ __ ] you we're gonna double
we're gonna triple down
and the guy on reddit said listen uh
paraphrasing john maynard kane said we
can be [ __ ]
longer than you can be solvent and they
were winning
that was what they said right and they
were winning the trade they had these
guys on the ropes they had them felted
okay and then what happens just at the
moment
where they're gonna like basically bust
them out of the game for good
robin hood shuts down the buy side of
the trade and so what does that do it
gives these hedge funds time to regroup
to unspool the trade to reposition and
save themselves
and to get out of the trade if they want
to get out of the trade you can never
take that 24 hour time period back
no matter what robin hood does now even
though multiple apps were strictly
trading
the public pointed the finger at robin
hood claiming that they were pressured
by wall street to shut it down
on the same day robinhood ceo vladteniv
went on a few of the mainstream media
channels to explain the decision
and it was absolutely awful to save you
the pain
he basically regurgitated a bunch of
alliance's pr department and legal team
wrote
avoided questions by talking about their
values and the founding of robin hood
denies being pressured by hedge funds to
limit trading this decision was not made
on the direction of any
market maker or uh other market
participants
didn't take full ownership and blame it
on social media and unprecedented volume
said the decision was to protect their
customers in order to protect the firm
and protect our customers and that no we
didn't do this because we didn't have
enough money to cover the fees
that there was a liquidity problem uh
inside the firm no no
there was no liquidity problem the next
day january 29
robinhood raises 1 billion dollars in
emergency cash from investors
because it definitely wasn't a liquidity
problem no no
there was no liquidity problem literally
they got on television yesterday
and they [ __ ] lied to americans right
to their face this is a company that was
insolvent
it cost individuals hundreds of millions
probably billions maybe even tens of
billions and these [ __ ] should
go to jail
robin hood also lists most restrictions
on stocks like gamestop game stock soars
back up before it gradually falls back
down
january 31st elon has robin hood ceo on
clubhouse to grill him about what
happened
at first vlad tries to pull the same pr
double speak that he pulled on tv
but elon wasn't having it well it's full
of beans man
what happened last week why do you uh
stop people why can people buy
the gamestop shares the people demand an
answer and they want to know the details
and the truth
okay so let me let me start by giving a
little bit of background
um so i'm the chief executive of robin
hood
right now actually
i'll go through this quickly don't worry
this is this is uh this is important
then he finally came to his senses and
acted like a normal human being
in a nutshell his rationale was that
when you buy a stock on robinhood
they don't actually fulfill your order
they send your order to what's called a
clearing house
which then takes two days to actually
transfer the stock over to you
without getting into the details too
much companies like robinhood then have
to deposit your money from the stock to
the clearing house
plus an additional fee depending on how
volatile the stock is
the day robin hood restricted trading
their fees apparently shot up to nearly
3 billion dollars that they had to pay
right at the moment
so they gave us a file with the deposit
and the request was around three billion
dollars
which is you know about an order of
magnitude more than what it typically is
up until now robin hood has only raised
a little over two billion dollars
so that three billion dollar fee would
have put them out of business right then
and there
why they didn't just come out and be
honest about this from the start is
beyond me
but that's probably the truth until more
information comes out since other apps
like weeble have told a similar story
we only had to stop the ability to buy
on the word from our clearing firm
that was unsure if they were going to be
able to clear them now whether or not
those were legitimate fees
or arbitrary fees made up to force them
to shut down trading
that is still up for discussion february
1st
robin hood raises another 2.4 billion in
emergency funds
which is a decent sign that robinhood
didn't do anything illegal because if
they did
investors probably wouldn't be injecting
billions of emergency dollars into them
all the while lawyers politicians former
central bankers that have received money
from hedge funds
all start coming out the woodwork
because of course they would
[Music]
but whether it's robin hood's fault or
the hedge fund's fault or the
clearinghouse's faults
it doesn't matter these are just the
symptoms of the disease of fragile
centralized power centralized power that
can restrict you limit you censor you at
any moment it pleases if you go against
his aim
and the masses have just realized that
maybe they have a lot more power than
they thought
and now they have the technology to back
it up and the people in power know it
now too
if we had to summarize all of this in a
nutshell that's what we know we know
that it started out as
people debating the true fundamental
value of gamestop
and it morphed into a momentum trade
where a bunch of folks got dogmatic
about a short
a bunch of folks got dogmatic about
being long
and belongs one and in the middle
what happened was a bunch of firms
basically decided at some point
to gate the ability for people to
transact in all of this
which i think caused a lot of economic
disruption and that was because they
didn't have the margin requirements and
i think it's because they were insolvent
i.e robin it's capitalism it's business
you know people love free markets and
limited
regulation until it affects them and i
mean everyone's talking about
regulating robin hood or regulating this
unless we're looking at
going the track of china and russia and
actually regulating our entire internet
you can't stop humans communicating to
each other you know everyone's
baffled all the time they're baffled
that a president can go direct to
consumer and not do briefings they're
baffled
that you know that taxis have been
disrupted everyone's always baffled when
is everybody who's watching this show
gonna understand that this thing called
the internet came along
and changed society this is printing
press
100x we are in the early stages
and people are struggling with
calibrating the massive
impact of this
[Music]
the last three weeks we learned social
media
users day-to-day people have a lot of
power because they have a lot of voice
but the wall street guys may not have
5.2 million subscribers but what do the
wall street guys have and hedge fund
people
have is they buy politicians
so they have power and influence the
reddit guys
have a voice but what's super
interesting about what happened this
week and i think is the most impactful
societally over time is that we're
seeing this phenomena
where individuals in aggregate
can believe something to be true and
make it true
and we saw this with tesla elon
was not hitting numbers that people
thought he was gonna hit margins
production volume etc
people were shorting the stock but
enough people believed
in the story that elon told about what
he wanted the future to look like
that they bought the stock and that gave
him the ability to do shelf offerings
raise additional capital
and ultimately build the business and
make it manifest in reality
that he said would happen and the same
is true of bitcoin
in all of these cases there was a belief
in something
and there was an aggregation of
individuals using social
media as a mechanism for sharing and
talking and engaging
and creating a collective outcome that
wouldn't have happened through a
centralized system or centralized
process
and wouldn't have happened in the
traditional way where history defines
the future
so maybe just maybe this was the spark
the modern day boston tea party to a
more
decentralized financial system you know
now maybe we found the first obvious use
case for a blockchain
right but when you take the broader
point of view of the implications that's
where
this becomes really shaky and really
scary and i think really enables
a decentralized movement that is going
to be a lot broader
than folks are really realizing at this
point you know folks don't want to be
trading
um on a system that tells them how to
trade and folks don't want to be
communicating on a system that tells
them how to communicate
i definitely think this is part of this
ongoing
populism versus the elites war and
social media is now the tool that
the people use to organize themselves
against these powerful elites it's why
we cannot allow censorship because it
always
comes down uh it to benefit the powerful
the elites against the people who are
trying to organize against them
i think this year is going to be a huge
year for cryptocurrencies and it's going
to be a major theme as we move closer to
figuring out exactly what happened this
week
but one thing's for sure this war
between the masses and the people in
power
has just begun i hope this
entire mess of the last week forces more
of us to get educated about how money
works
because if we don't get educated about
how money works this is not gonna go
away
very good guys quick reminder that i
will be going live on stereo on friday
at 12 p.m u.s pacific time with none
other than captain sinbad
carl jung is my deep deep lover and
another one on monday at 12 with arvid
ali where he's going to be responding to
all the hate comments he's received on
the kathy wood video
it's going to be very fun i can't wait
for them and you shouldn't either so you
should go to stereo.com
jaytran and click the notification bell
on the show so you get notified when we
go live
if you're watching this after those
lives already happen you can catch the
full replays of them
plus the first one we did on evading
taxes legally
with the link below at stereo dot com
jake tran
i feel like i'm saying this every single
month now but this is by far the most
research i put into a single video
it was very tedious and i really wanted
to get it right for you guys so if you
guys think i did a good job
and that more people should learn about
this stuff be sure to leave a comment
below and just write out iwatch to the
end
that way it gives the youtube algorithm
a nice little boost and
click that share button down below there
too and share it with your closest
friend
just one friend that's all i'm asking if
you are new to this channel we make
video essays just like this one every
single week
on the most provocative things in the
world of business for your viewing
pleasure
for free so you might as well subscribe
because you can always dislike and
unsubscribe
and leave me your best hate comments
anytime you want so you have nothing to
lose
and everything's game that is going to
wrap it up for this video thank you so
much for watching you've been awesome
i've been jake stay dangerous out there
and i will see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you